okay for people joining this live stream
this is going to be a fairly short
meeting
uh because i have to go um about
uh you're on that design
um and shall we start off here
yeah yeah so it's mainly about net
function
and uh i think we you validate most of
the design last time
so you want a small recapitulation
before we go to the last thing to
validate okay i mean basically this is a
compiler that goes to
a native mx netcode is that correct
to yeah close to our
interface okay uh um
so to our network language let's say
uh also okay so it's a it's a companion
we could say to the compiler
it's not really compiling the code has
anybody talked to christopher about his
efforts to design a new layer for the
compiler
no i think he should okay
okay i mean i don't i don't know what
what uh he's been
working hard to to um
basically put a layer on top of the
compiler so that it's actually usable
that's right so the intermediate code is
usable basically
okay okay so so the idea is that that
function would return a net function
that's something that we
believe is best like at some point we
thought maybe shoot a net graph
uh but the nice thing that returning in
net function is that you can still read
the function
and we would like to have both
uh that you can both sees a graph and
the the function well how do you edit
the code
uh you'll have to read it you have to
recreate the net function i don't think
we can so you can convert it to a net
graph
by doing just net graph on that chain
depending on what it is
and and you can do net extract on a take
but this would go out of the net
function this would return a net graph
right so edition and honestly addition
of
code is not super easy as
edition of graph
this is
modify modifying the the function
yeah noah as an expression it's going to
be
harder than okay let me just understand
what's going to happen
so net function in principle i can get
this net function
and then i can just say net train of
this net function is that correct
yes yes so yeah net function works like
any other network
any other layer to be precise okay so
what's the question
here so i mean there's a question of
what can be in this net function what
does it do when
when you give it something that it can't
have inside it
this our our idea is that it will be a
compiled layer when it cannot
uh when it cannot go to our presentation
yes yes yes okay so this yeah
and uh well so okay so that means that
um what okay so
what you're suggesting is that the net
function
okay so i mean you're going to get a
summary blob from the net function
and that summary blob
i mean to me it seems like you just need
a button that says show me the code
yes exactly it's not function and it's
it's like in the summary blob it's just
to show me the code button
and given that you can't really edit it
i mean
how do you get given that you have
something that is output as a net
function
and you want to edit it i mean the input
form of that net graph if i'm not
mistaken
is an editable thing correct
the input form not really you know but
how do i edit this if i've just been
extract net net replace net extract like
you have specific
no but i don't want to do that i want to
just edit because
you see it's a different story here okay
that's no good that's no good that's no
good that's no good
no no but you you have a weight i mean
the point is this acts like
graph you cannot do that with graph as
well
yes you can with graph
well graph itself no you cannot although
you should be able to
but you can't right now but but this
particular thing of not storing enough
information
that's the same story story has been
wait a minute same story that
that has been the case there is enough
information there but it says there
isn't enough
in that case yes in that case yes
because because you copied you copied
the
the output no sorry you copied the
visualization
and i understand that but i'm saying
that like data set
there should be a stripe down there that
says do you want to store this in the
notebook
if i just copied that what's that
definitely i agree yeah
the classifier function does that and
we're going to put that to to everyone
okay all right fine okay so the issue
here is
see i think it's a different story
because i think that
very few people are going to want to
edit raw net graphs
you know i mean how do i get back the
net graph from this
ned graph no no no how do i get back
an editable form of this net graph right
now you're going to tell me i don't want
it because the editable form of the net
graph is full of weight
matrices and all kinds of crud
you you can get sort of input formula is
it in the net information or something
that you can get input form
yeah but you won't have the weights no
no it's not useful
right so so my point is with netflix
okay both in both cases both in that
function and with this the unweight
untrained version is useful to get but
with net function
people will seriously want the untrained
version because
they just wrote it as code you see what
i'm saying and they'll want to tweak
that code because
mere mortals are expected to write net
functions
whereas that's not the case with net
graphs well
if we return the net function head
that's not so complicated because you
could store inside a string which
contains the original code
exactly exactly we'll store the string
and you will be able to extract the
whole function
for sure in one way or another it can be
with net extract or it can also be with
information
or it would be something where you could
just like click a thing here
and just like we do with control equals
you've just got the code there
and if you want to pop in you can you
could you could edit it in place
and in the output form and then you that
would be
like you just say okay and it gets
revalidated well hold on
hold on hold on hold on hold on hold on
that doesn't make sense look what we
should do
is the same thing we do elsewhere it's a
it's a you know we should not disable
copy down
so if you put in an input you know you
click it into some form
you start editing it will copy down the
cell and then you've got a piece of
input again
and then the way that it would work is
there would be code
you know that there's basically a panel
there that you can edit
with code and you know you change it
and it's it's an inputable thing again
now i don't know how common that will be
because i think the more common thing is
people probably the more common things
people will go back to the source
the place where they got the source from
in the source notebook and edit that
maybe that's the right thing to do yeah
i assume but that's pretty cool that you
i mean that's a good idea
we haven't thought about that that you
can could modify
inside the box right and just copy that
i'm not sure if that really works we'll
try
a copy down sorry
um the the well what i mean by copy down
something like this if i say
range of of 10
and oops oh my god
okay now i edit this right that copies
down
oh yeah it broke no this is i'm sorry
this is copy down right it broke
the connection what is going on here
yeah okay it it it made that into an it
made it into an input cell
i i'm actually surprised that this isn't
yeah
i guess that would only work when it's a
small network because we
uh oh i guess when you specifically
decide to
copy and notebook the network
which you know in general they are a
little bit big
you don't want to do that right but okay
but
let's let's just go back still i don't
think it's a terrible idea because you
have a lot of loss functions
that where you play and net function
will really
shine with them and maybe you want to do
a plus one and then
becomes plus two you want to try
different things
exactly that's what i'm saying that
unlike i mean my understanding of this
workflow is unlike the case of net graph
where only on those rare special
occasions
do you actually edit it directly um
yeah ethan is asking will this have the
same problems with element-wise layer
where only a few things work inside it
well that's what you're claiming is that
you can do the general
so long as the compiler can handle it
you can do it but of course that relies
on the fact that the compiler is working
quickly in things
yeah and and i think it's important that
you plug this into christopher's new
you know compiler calling framework but
i i would be curious to see what is not
supported that is useful because
for me like the coverage has improved in
the
i'm always improving it and now i see
nothing okay so ethan mentions
graphs or nd solve right
no i mean if if the the guy who is
commenting
could say what is not working in the
element why is there anything
oh okay but uh
totally requires the callback into the
corner because yeah that's going to
require a callback
yeah yeah yeah but the question is do we
have the plumbing to do a call back
yeah that's what matthew was working on
with compiled layer
and so the compiler does uses the
compilers plumbing
to do the callback correct yes yes yes
there's still a problem of automatic
differentiation that is being worked on
um so in in the first version we haven't
had our meeting about compile layer but
in our first version basically you will
have to specify the the backward pass
you know the gradient sort of and um
but um depending on how advanced
is the work that robnapp is doing on
automatic differentiation
you might not have to do that for for
most cases
right now and dissolve will be
automatically differentiable but
you know no that's very very very hard
uh yeah yeah although there are
presumably numerical ways to do
automatic differentiation
which you know on the fly so to speak
that could work i don't really
understand that i mean you know if your
param
if you have a parameter in the nd solve
and you want to differentiate with
respect to it on the fly i'm sure that's
possible
it's just not so easy
okay so the thing to decide maybe if you
go
on top they're not super exciting things
but
we we so there's this net array thing
that has to be introduced
to represent an array uh but that is
learnable
so so you can specify
its shape you know let array first
argument would be the shape that array 3
4 in the list will be
something else shape 3 4. uh you could
also specify some values
let array 3 4 and then you actually put
an array
that's the the current values and
well the name is not good because
basically
array the function is a thing that
generates an array
of specified shape
right from a function so i mean i could
imagine something
maybe maybe maybe where it says you know
net array
automatic comma shape
see what i'm saying to represent an
array that has no content yet
but you know has shape but not
you know whatever form but not
function you know it's it's it's got a
shape but it doesn't have any content
yet
yeah making sense but otherwise
i don't really like the the i mean which
functions i mean
it's been a bit random which functions
are trainable and which functions are
not
right
do you understand what i'm saying yes
basically
it's it's only the the layers that are
trainable
uh of the language and uh or something
you construct with this thing
whatever we call it which can be like
you know learnable uh
you know unfortunately we call that
array in
usually people call that weights um
where do we call that array
i don't know why this decision was made
where is it called array
people call it waits for multiple like
no no no
i'm sorry i'm sorry where do we go where
so either in the documentation and also
in the layer panels like if you do
linearly i don't care about those and
the function names where are we using
array
in the in symbol names yes where are we
so we have examples
on your screen constantly constant array
layer yeah
they want to rename by the way that's
the next point uh
because we think it's a bad name this is
rename it to array layer so this is a
typical example of
array in the name of a symbol oh yeah
but we don't have it yet do we
no no we don't have to discuss it
because
no no we never have it no sorry we have
constantary layer
we have constantly already i understand
do we have any other
array layer net shared array look yeah
here net share the rate this thing to
share the weights basically the array
and
okay so net shared away is something
very similar to what you're now
proposing to call that array
right no yes it's an array
it's a it's some kind of weird array
object that lives in the neural net
framework
well net shared array is basically
an inherit wrapper to represent that
some array is shared between
more layers so yeah but it's very
similar actually
yeah it's super similar it's the
symbolic representation
of an array yeah you're right exactly
you're right you're right you're right
you're right
well but okay because it's shared or not
but no no it's exactly the same
in one case it's shared and now it is it
is the same
look at the communication material when
you do not share the array
you can only specify a name which is
purely symbolic if you do array layer or
we understand we are looking but
it represents an array yes yes yes it's
not a layer it's not
whatever it's an array
one way you have a specific array well
defined
with numbers inside it while with not
shared array you don't have that
it's just a reference to something no
not necessarily sometimes it's
just a shape guys i'm going to have to
go very soon here so
we probably have to reschedule this um
to continue i think that um
uh i mean since we have net shared array
it makes
even more sense to call it net array but
i don't think either of those names is
right i think we need to rethink the way
that this notion
of a of a an object okay
look an object that basically is passed
around and have its in has its innards
reconstituted by training that's
basically what we're talking about here
right and
that's something that you know we need
to understand which things have that
property
you know in other words
i'm confused by the semantics of this
and i'm confused by
if you put a net array into a net
function and then you get the net
function back out again
is has the net array been updated or not
or when has it been updated when can you
edit the code
when it's an opaque net array that has
been changed not changed etc
i think it's something yeah what's that
i think it's updated yes and it would
work
if if you do a basic operation on that
array it would work
uh i mean there's two possibilities
either it evaluates or it does not
when you actually do net array and put
stuff in it you could evaluate to an
array or it could stay as a net array no
i don't think it should evaluate to an
array i don't think i think it will be a
mistake i think it wants to be a
um but i think it wants to be a thing
that like a sparse array
just sits there and you know you can
poke at it
and do things to it and it returns
another net array
right you say net array you train the
net array it returns another net array
making sense just like think about it
like a sparse array
and maybe that's the way we should think
about this
that it's it's got you know a sparse
array is something which has some kind
of
complicated content and a shape
basically
yeah and yeah no type of thing i like
that i hope
implementation wise it won't be too hard
to to make everything works with that
but
otherwise i like this design right so
then then that way it would kind of it
would if it used that as the pattern
and then i would be more game for the
net array name
right um
you know it would look something like
that would be a net array with some
you know you know that type of thing
yeah
and and so what then it is
yeah it's just an array i mean it's a
little bit unclear to me why it isn't
just
something like a sparse array what
special features does it have
other than that it is trainable when
inside a training system
uh because no that's the difference you
just uh
specified but i'm sorry what are you
saying
can you do a special way of missing not
really
you see what i mean like you don't have
to specify it you can just say it's
something of this size and
and uh but one one thing i should
mention
is that we might need this in other
places later
so maybe a more generic name would be
great well i mean
we need to understand exactly what the
semantics are this is an array
which where its values are being updated
somehow externally i mean every array
has that property you know every array
where we give it input you feed it to a
matrix function
it comes back with something else
[Music]
ethan is complaining that the compiler
doesn't work with image or image 3d
it's probably the wrong group to talk
about that with but i know that's that's
a um i mean that's certainly people
are aware of that um
will that function work for writing
custom layers and losses
should do right isn't that the point
yes yes i mean it's along with with a
compiled layer
um hey look i have to
okay if you want to discuss that you're
going to have to wait a couple of
minutes because i'm i need to
um wait why don't you talk
to talk among yourselves i'll be back in
a couple of minutes okay
okay
yeah i was thinking maybe we would use
something like that array
like if we do probabilistic programming
or something like that you know
sometimes you have to define
these parameters
that's kind of what we're deciding is
the parameters of the model
but is it a wrapper that we did
well in the cases that you're thinking
of is it something around an area
it should be something very similar you
know i say a equal nataree or blah blah
blah you know
and it's a way so that inside the code
we specify that a
is a learnable parameter i mean all
learnable array rather
and uh and having a net here would be a
bit weird
but we can always supersede after
if it happens that you know we use it in
a bunch of other place we change the
name
and uh and here we go and we deprecate
the old one
that would still work so maybe it's
it's not it's a non-problem for now
it would be called like you know
parameter you know like learnable
i don't know
how would we call that
learnable array
parametric array
and you already put that in the system
by the way sorry i'm changing
conversation
concentrate layer to a rayleigh yes like
this you're already in the tent right
yes we should we should well
for me we already discussed it during
weekly meeting but that's the thing that
i said that
what is messy is not not like devin is
doing a great job into doing knots but
i don't know using something like tweaky
or red mine to
you know to have an architect yeah
something where you have a project
and and you click and you yeah you can
see many times
what was decided because it absorbs many
times that
some of us didn't get that something was
decided
and you understand it
for me i'm a fan of redmine i like
tricky and i know that
some people don't take tricky so okay
let's give a keep a dread mind if we
could work with
this like no but honestly and you can
organize your project
like uh yeah you are yeah
i could i could suggest the uh the
dreaded j word
jira no no but david you have to
convince all people in the team to use
it
that's the only way to because otherwise
because we have many tools we have uh
what was the name of the tour
uh
look i believe you if you say that
stephen approved that you prove that and
let's move on they were bad named
bad name
array layer much better array times
layer
replace layer
the thing is that we wanted to remove
the constant but at this meeting i have
the feeling that
stephen wants to yeah he's not happy
about
array right right that we we started to
propagate everywhere
and we say tensor maybe sometimes but
what does he want to say i don't know
no no because the weight is not good and
weight is for multiplicative
so for me it's the three parameters it's
how i call them
that's true only real world
that i know for them there might not be
something better
yeah normally it's like it's parameters
learnable parameters because
learn about parameter layer you know
it's bad
learnable parameter times layer
yeah we have to keep an eye
hi guys solved everything yes
okay we think we have to keep this array
thing because
it's really like weight is not really
not even the right thing
because you have weight biases like
weight is really used only for the
multiplicative
parameters so parameters is actually
your learnable parameter is the right
thing
but you know for what
for so for example so we okay
we're discussing about concentrate layer
constant times layer constant plus layer
which we believe are very bad names
so we want to change them especially if
they're not concentrated is that correct
are they are they learning
they are learnable exactly exactly
what's the difference between those
layers of the array layer
rather yes exactly exactly so the
difference is that one is a layer and
the other one is not a layer
so a layer you have to give an input
sorry
to another viewpoint is that you can
still see those as layers and in fact
it's called constant array layer as of
now
and it's just a layer that doesn't take
any input so that
that is why it was called constant which
i don't personally like but
it's not completely meaningless yeah
it's very
different with net array yeah
the difference with net array is that
net array if it's defined net array you
know blah blah plus three will work
whereas array layer will have to do
array layer open bracket close bracket
plus three
you see what i mean it's a layer so it
takes an
input in that case empty and then
returns something it will return the
array so array layer yeah you give open
brackets
is a function which which is things
right
whereas it's just a thing which can be
used inside net function
that is just represents an array exactly
actually
first in principle again constant times
layer and constant plus layer
you could say that they are just sugar
if you have net array they are just
sugar for a function like a trading
layer
of uh input plus that's true yes
times net array yeah yeah maybe we'll
deprecate them
actually it's written deprecated or
array times layer duplicated or rep so
that's exactly because of your point
if we have net array we can duplicate
constant times and constant plus
fine okay so constant array layer
just becomes a thing that is a function
version i don't understand why we need
it i mean it's basically net function
net array isn't it
yes what what's the um uh i think so yes
what specifically is it i mean that net
function
takes a function okay so
so what it would be specifically is net
function
of net array
blah blah blah um ampersand
right that's what it is isn't it
yes yes
okay i mean
the question whether we have a separate
function with that name it seems you
know a different issue
but i think if that's what it is is
it should be called net array layer
because it is a net array which is just
operating as a layer yeah yeah yeah
i mean if net array is a thing then this
is just the layered version of that
do we really need it if we have a net
function can we drop all this business
and just keep in that array
and probably not probably we don't need
it but if we do need it it should be net
array layer
we may need it for just things to look
elegant
yeah okay
yeah when people um
yeah people use it people use it because
that's kind of a way to do custom
not truly custom but somewhat custom
layer
so it's used right there's some comments
on our live stream here a net function
for torch users tutorial
i can't comment on that but it's um um
yeah okay examples of onyx import to net
function that's a
wood onyx import to net function or onyx
imports
how would that work i thought it's
important to our layer structure
um well i so what will happen is that
if we encounter a lungs operator which
needs net function in order to be
expressed in the framework then of
course it will
as of now we support like in 12 2 will
support around
i think it was like 70 or 80 young's
operators and
none of them using that function right
now but i mean if we need it of course
we'll do it
um
question here about optimizing models
and whether they fit in the cache
i think that's at the lower level
question whether things fit in l1 caches
and so on is
is not something we are handling that's
something that's at the mx
net layer maybe maybe not even a mxnet
like when you're speaking of cpu caches
maybe
you know optimized uh
math back-ends that an accent uses such
as you know
intel and kl or the
the new library dnl then
that stuff you know is is where you deal
with this
super super low level optimization but i
don't think
not even the mxnet developers deal with
that
um listen i'm gonna have to go because
i'm i'm i think at least unless i'm not
getting reminders about
i thought i was supposed to go to an
event in them
one minute so um i think i better
just check unless something unless i was
mistaken here hold on one
second no i'm not mistaken
um i need to go unfortunately so we're
making some progress but we'll need to
meet again
yep okay thanks guys